طيب دكتور سالنا الناس برايك من الاقوى
لمقاومه تتاثر بالاخبار السيئه نرجع نسمع
راي الشارع ونرجع لك دكتور
[موسيقى]
لقد تاثرا الرجل طبعا لانه الرجل همم
بحكم عقله تقريبا اما الانثى بتحقق بتحكم
على طوبتها اغلب الاوقات يعني ممكن تقرا
خبر يكون ما له داعي اصلا تمام
وبتتعاطف معه المراه طبعا اكيد لان المراه
عندها شفافيه وحساسه اكثر من الرجل وطبعا
وعاطفيه وهذا هي طبعا دائما المراه هي
بتتفاعل معي كل اي احداث سواء الحزن او
الفرح
[موسيقى]
الست
تتاثر
ممكن نحطها حنان
بتحب تسمع اخبار سيئه
يعني لانه بصراحه مبلد يعني متعود على
اخبار السيئه ما في اخبار منيحه
[موسيقى]
فش حدا ما بتاثر بالاخبار السيئه الكل
بيتاثر بس الرجل يعني بتوقع انه عنده قدر
على انه يكبه مشاعر شويه يعني مثلا ممكن
انه يكون حزين اكثر من ورا بس مش يعني مش
بسهوله يبكي
[موسيقى]